and then let's look at i want to look at
leopard print
karen as well um
yeah this one's really good this one's
really good and we're going to watch
this one in a moment
let me just make sure i didn't i didn't
forget any thank yous
i do want to say thanks to the eight
additional people who just grabbed uh
twitch
subscriptions i appreciate that um a few
other new members to thank i want to say
thanks to
lindsay berger as well as
jimmy upchurch for signing up at
joinedpakman.com
appreciate that we are doing it's a
triple threat today quite frankly we're
doing
patreon members
and twitch patreon.com
david pakman show join pacman.com
twitch.tv slash david pakman it all
counts today
let me just look at people's reactions
to this stuff i would quote the anti-gay
baker lawsuit for the right to refuse
service
very well said 75 percent in oklahoma
stores don't wear masks
fine but that's also because the stores
aren't enforcing it
karen's shopping list cauliflower apple
cider vinegar quinoa
essential oils diapers johnson and
johnson no more maggot ears
shampoo nice nice uh nice shopping list
paul says pacman what has been your
largest 2020 2021 donation
i think the biggest the largest single
donations
they're all pretty close on our website
the biggest membership we have is 480 a
year
and we got a bunch of those and then i
think the biggest super chat you can
send is 500 and i think we got a bunch
of those so i think it's right about 500
has been the biggest uh 2020 2021
donation okay let's get to leopard print
karen this might actually be my favorite
of all of them
this was a starbucks i forgot this is
starbucks not
i i think i said something else before
hand off of me
you are kidnapping me i want a person
what is your name
i'll give you money take your hands off
on them
you are killed you don't have the right
sir get your hands
off me i've done nothing wrong i am not
a criminal get
your hands together so again remember
that a lot of these disputes are
the cops show up and everybody says oh
it's a cr i'm a criminal well
no the you're there at the store's
pleasure
and as long as they're not saying we're
not serving you because you're a woman
or we're not serving you because you're
white or we're not serving you because
you're
a christian right as long as there's not
a protected class violation
once a business says you've got to go
you've got to go
so that they don't seem to really
understand that
get your hands off of them
that's a violation take your hand off
now the person filming is it her
daughter because later in the video she
says darling or something like that and
you hear the officer say
don't stand behind me so i think this is
someone with her constitution
okay so she cited the constitution let's
keep a list
she's so far cited the constitution and
that she hasn't committed a crime
you don't have the right to do this you
take a depiction this is so
illegal you
in all seriousness guys if this was a
black male they'd be in handcuffs
already right
does anyone in the chat disagree that if
this had been a black male
who was not leaving after starbucks
called the cops they would already be in
handcuffs forcibly
does anyone disagree with that in the
chat
take your hand off of me take your
violating my personhood by touching her
she is being denied the right to being a
person
it has been taken away i have my first
amendment right
first amendment so now now i'm losing
track
i actually have to make a note so it was
a constitutional violation
a personhood violation a first
amendment violation there was one more
though what was the other one
that was violated
and oh not a criminal okay so so far
there are four different
explanations made here
i'm asking him to take his hand off and
he has no right to kidnap me
oh and kidnapping kidnapping okay
you are let go of me no let go of me i'm
happy
this is because the police department
are ignorant of the constitutional
rights
this is why this man has his hand on me
and he's on my personhood
she he is he is actually he's standing
on her personhood with his jack boot
he's jack booting her personhood i have
the right to protect
my personhood no sir take your hand off
of me
personhood's a legal concept right
like the idea she's talking about
personhood as if it's a physical item
take your hand off take one steel mic
first now okay accuses of
purse theft purse
theft
i like how this now this guy is a
no-nonsense guy
this guy comes in and simply says is she
out of here and when he's told yes
they just carry her out
take a picture of these guys
what is the that almost sounds like an
like a joyous noise that woohoo
you're getting all this you see this
this is
are you filming this sweetheart are you
filming this sweetheart
stop it you cannot arrest now i assume
the sirens in the background are not for
this call
but there is a bit of an ambiance that's
added to it from the sirens in the
background that that does fit
although i can't imagine that that's for
this particular incident i've done
nothing illegal
i have done nothing illegal
stop it
oh no i had a friend who had a parrot
that lived a very long life that sounded
exactly like them
put your arms back uh oh now we're
now we've got resisting they don't
usually pull out the resisting on the
middle-aged white ladies i have to admit
i am not under arrest leave me alone
after watching this video i thought
maybe this was about a leopard attack
okay so that's uh i okay i lost my pen
because i gotta grab that
yeah so this this is a mind virus that's
um
that that's spreading but it does seem
that she's wrong so during this she made
a number of false claims
she claimed that she was being kidnapped
she indicated she couldn't be asked to
leave because she had not committed a
crime
she said her first amendment rights were
being violated she said her personhood
was being violated
the constitution was being violated
it's a two-minute video her purse had
was being
stolen and she also wrongly
wrongly claimed that she was not getting
arrested
which it seems as though she was um
oh there's a second part hold on a
second
where can i find that where can i find
part two
leopard print trader joe's part two hold
on
um oh i put parrot two
hold on where is part two can anyone
help me find that
i need to see part two
search google it was on twitter
um leopard print karen part
two part two of the leopard print karen
arrest oh okay
let's see here all right
put your arms back stop resisting i am
not under arrest
leave me alone i am not under arrest
i can't breathe i can't breathe oh that
is rich
oh can you imagine i mean after after
the george floyd debacle
i can't breathe is uh i mean think
that is that that has so much other
meaning to it
that puts it puts this in a completely
different uh
the i can't the introduction of i can't
breathe adds another layer to this
all together let's continue
[Music]
oops just stand back on the sidewalk
stay back on the sidewalk please
honey come here get my purses trying to
steal my purse from
no they're not can you imagine these
three officers are going to steal her
purse
hey copy her first man yes can you sit
back
stand on the sidewalk stop interfering
stand on the sidewalk it's a false
arrest hold on i want to add that as
well
false arrest because they didn't say
she's under arrest
lack arrest
privileges
no no okay no no don't touch my purse
come get my first sweetheart
in the name of jesus no no
oh no now it went into another level now
she's invoking jesus
in the name of jesus i come against
these principalities and powers this lie
this abuse
this abuse honey come get my purse i'm
scared
no ma'am you're gonna they're coming in
from south america and
strike and strike
i'm sorry okay that's my
i am in charge
why do these always go this way like the
escalation the sequence is always
identical
i'm not trust that you can't trespass in
a public business
they read the pro okay let's add that
cannot
trespass at public
business this i'm going to need a second
page no
they can't sir this is a lot no i'm not
sending you your card
stop that you're under arrest can i get
her a card ma'am no you can't
she's under arrest it's her property
you're not getting her first stay back
wow so part two really escalating all
right so
the full list here is now i can't even
read my own handwriting
she claimed she was being kidnapped by
police she said she couldn't be arrested
because she didn't commit a crime
she said her first amendment rights were
being violated her personhood was being
violated
the constitution was being violated her
purse was being stolen
um she said she's not under arrest
she claimed it was a fake arrest she
claimed the police officers lack the
privileges
to arrest her i guess she means the
power to arrest her
and that one cannot be trespassed from a
public business and that was in about
four minutes
can you imagine
it's it's absolutely nuts
yeah okay